[Musique]
c'est à Saint-Philippe que s'est tenue
la 2e édition du Forum territorialisé de
l'action sociale et de l'insertion les
acteurs sociaux du département de la
commune ainsi que d'autres partenaires
étaient présents pour proposer aux
visiteurs l'ensemble des mesures
d'accompagnement à l'insertion
professionnelle pour nos publics cibles
qui sont les demandurs d'emploi et
également les bénéficiaires du RSA ù
toute personne en VO d'insertion
l'objectif c'est de le faire connaître
sur le territoire de Saint-Philippe les
partenaires qui euh sont euh à
disposition pour transmettre des
informations notamment sur le volet
action social du département notamment
la prévention l'insertion sociale
également sur les métiers qui sont
actuellement donc en émergence sur le
territoire dans le domaine de
l'agrotourisme de l'aquaponie également
dans les métiers de mobilité douce
notamment au travaers d' partenaire la
Sud c'est l'objectif de ce forum c'est
euh être présent sur un même territoire
avec un ensemble acteur pour pouvoir
répondre aux besoins de nos usagers de
nos bénéficiaires plus d'une soixantaine
de partenaires et près de 400 visiteurs
ont parcouru les stands d'information
les filières de l'agriculture de
l'artisanat des services et de l'armée
entre autres présentent leurs formation
ainsi que les emplois proposés dans leur
secteur c'est de d'informer et de
présenter vraiment l'ensemble des
métiers disponibles dans l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace c'est plus de 50
métiers dans 13 domaines d'activités
différents accessibles à partir de 100
diplômes jusqu'à bac+ 5
on aalisé tout un donc un un dispositif
qui s'appelle trempl station un
dispositif d'accompagnement renforcé
accès sur du coaching et de
l'accompagnement individualisé et qui
donc est de très courte durée ça fait
donc 80 he et donc au bénéfice donc des
bénéficiaires du RSA qui de qui
autrement n'aurait pas pu se déplacer
jusqu'à 5 pi ce forum territorialisé a
pour objectif d'amener les actions
sociales et de l'insertion au plus près
de la population rapprocher les offres
de service alleer vers les habitants
c'est aujourd'hui le cas pour les
saintphilippois et les saint
[Musique]
josphois